I learned how to by dancing re I
just want to let you know like if you
weren't dancing re in the recck room in
Queens you don't good then I got the
Chevy Lumina ooh mint green and the
wheel was like that permanently and then
I crashed that within 3 days I try to
hit somebody in my building what they do
we'll get to that he was on I was taking
like project steroids my boy musclehead
Ed was making the trend so he was
shooting in your ass yeah he'll hurt you
he'll hurt your
butt where is Adam Silver from I don't
know but I'll tell you this he gives a
real good hip-hop handshake that the
tone crazy like what up and word or not
no
way he said it to me with his eye this
Chef Dove oh man did you warm them up
this is silly right here hold on
you want to know where each are from or
do you want to kind of be a little
surpris let me do it
blind